What is that? -This is Tantalum. Which bit? - That bit. This bit here?
Tantalum is another element which has become more important
in recent years. The importance of Tantalum is that it is used in
making capacitors in mobile phones. Capacitors are the components that
store up charge in electricity, and you make really small and
effective capacitors from Tantalum. So, Tantalum has gone from being
an element that is not wildly exciting to something
that you find in every mobile phone.  -So this is a sample of
Tantalum wire. It's very high  quality research sample.
0.2 mm in diameter. Tantalum, haven't got a clue what it's used for.
www.periodicvideos.com
. . . . . . . . . . . .
Captions by www.SubPLY.com